네, 안녕하세요. 빌사입니다. 어,
제가 오늘 사실 목 상태가 좀 좋지
않은데 여러분들한테 꼭 알려 드려야
될 정보가 있어 가지고 좀 급하게
카메라를 켰습니다. 일단 여러분들한테
알려 드릴게 최근에 그 다주택자
양도세 중과 관련돼서 이슈가 좀
많잖아요. 기사들도 좀 많이 나갔고.
근데 여러분들이 이때 [음악]
상가주택 건물, 다가구 주택, 단독
주택 건물을 싸게 살 수 있는 기회가
있습니다. 그래서 오늘 제가 중요한
거 설명드릴테니까 딱 5분만 집중해
주시면 좋을 것 같습니다. 일단 첫
번째로 알아야 될 키워드가 5월 9일
전에 계약해야죠. 5월 9일 전에
계약해야지 그니까 매도인 분 파시는
분이 양도세 중가를 안 받아요.
다주택자인 경우에이 전까지는 그런
건물들을 되게 싸게 살 수 있는
기회입니다. 아무래도이 중가가 되냐가
안 되냐에 따라서 세율 차기가 굉장히
큽니다. 그래서 5월 9일 키워드를
좀 기억하시면 좋을 거 같고 그리고
여러분들 6월 1일이 무슨 날이죠?
바로 재산세 부가 기준일입니다.
[음악]
네. 6월 1일 소유자가 이제
재산세나 종부세를 납부하는 거예요.
파는 사람 입장에서는 5월 말까지
잔금하기를 원해요. 왜냐면 6월 1일
소유자가 재산세뿐만 아니라 종부세도
같이 내기 때문에. [음악] 그래서
여러분들이 파시는 분한테 협상할 때
5월 9일 전까지 계약하고 그리고
잔금을 5월 말까지 하게 되면 가격
협상에 굉장히 유리할 수 있습니다.
진짜 시세보다 뭐 10% 이게 아니라
거의 20% 뭐 30%까지도 협상이
가능해요. 이것 때문에. 그래서
여러분들이 다주택자 건물을 소유하신
분들의 미즈를 좀 파악해 가지고
협상을 하신다면 가격 조율에 있어서
굉장히 유리한 조건으로 건물을
매수하실 수 있습니다. 그리고
여러분들이 계약하실 때 아셔야 될게
용도 변경 조건으로 계약해야 돼요.
잠금 전에 이제 파는 사람 입장에선
계약시에만 주택이면 뭐 장기보유 특별
공제라든지 어 그런 세금 이슈가
없어요. 그리고 이제 매수인
입장에서는 계약시의 주택이었다
하더라도 잔금시에 근생으로 매입하게
되면 취득세 중가 없습니다. 그냥
4.6%만 내시면 됩니다. 그래서
용도 변경 조건으로 매입해서 뭐
나중에 뭐 신축을 할 수도 있고 근데
요즘에 신축비가 너무 비싸 가지고
보통은 용도 변경한 다음에 리모델링을
많이 합니다. 네. 그래서 어 매수인
입장에서는 무조건 용도 변경 조건으로
매입을 해야 돼요. 그래야 대출도 잘
나옵니다. 그리고 이런 경우도 있을
것 같아요. 그냥 용도 변경 조건이
아니라 상가 주택. 그래서 뭐 이렇게
예를 들면은 여기가 상가고 여기가
이제 주택. 그래서 이렇게 상가주택
건물을 살 수도 있거든요. 근데이
경우도 상가 비율이 좀 더 높으면
대출이 되게 잘 나옵니다. 어 물론
이제 주택 방마다 공제가 되긴 하지만
우리가 지금 일반적으로 아파트 살 때
대출이 거의 안 나오잖아요. 그래서
진짜 뭐 현금 10억 있다 하더라도
뭐 20억짜리 못 사잖아요. 근데
상가주택은 살 수 있습니다.
상가주택. [음악]
대체적으로 봤을 때 현금 10억이면
만는 진짜 20억 좀 넘는 그런
상가주택 건물도 살 수 있습니다.
그래서 내가 만약에 난 아파트가 좀
그렇고 건물을 사고 싶다라고 하면
레버리지를 잘 활용할 수 있어요.
상가주택은. 지금 시장에 상가주택
건물도 좀 많이 나올 것으로 좀
예상이 됩니다. 그리고 마지막으로
제가 좀 설명드릴게 [음악] 제일
중요한 거예요. 황금성. 황금성이
뭐냐면 건물은 황금성이 [음악]
낮아요. 그니까 이제 건물이 잘 안
팔려요. 건물이 아파트보다는 황금성이
매우 떨어집니다. 그래서 제가
말씀드렸던 그런 주택 건물을
사신다라고 하면 황금성이 높은데 사야
돼요. 그래야 땅의 가치도 좋기
때문에 나중에 근생으로 바꿔서도 시세
차액을 볼 수 있기 때문에 그냥 막
주택 건물 싸게 나왔다고 그냥 애매한
지역에 갈 거보다는 이게 일단
핵심이에요. 황금성이 높은 그런
지역에 투자를 꼭 하셔야 됩니다.
네. 제가 다시 한번 정리하자면 5월
9일 전에 계약을 해야 됩니다.
그래야지 다주택자분들이 혜택을 받을
수가 있어요. 그리고 6월 1일
재산세 부가 기준일인 거 여러분 제가
진짜 귀에 피가 나도록 얘기를
드렸는데 6월 1일 재산세 부가
기준일 때문에 파시는 분 입장에서는
무조건이 전에 잔금을 하길 원합니다.
그래서 만약에 가격 협상을 한다라고
했을 때 5월 말까지 잔금을 치르게
된다라면 굉장히 좋은 가격에 어
매입할 [음악] 수 있는 그런
기회들이 있고 그리고 주택 건물을
계약할 때는 주택 상태로 계약을
하지만 잔금 전에 용도 변경 조건으로
매입을 해야 되고 무엇보다 이거를
하는 전제가 무조건 황금성이 좋은
건물을 매입해야 [음악] 돼요.
그래서 건물이 잘 팔리는 지역 예를
들어서 뭐 송수동이라든지 뭐
한남동이라든지 아니면 강남 그 특정
동네 있잖아요. 뭐 신사나 뭐
청남이나 뭐 그런 황금성이 높은
지역의 주택 건물을 매입하는게
핵심입니다. 그래서 일단 황금성이
높은 건물들은 뭐 최근에 뭐 실거래가
이제 공개가 많이 돼 있어 가지고 뭐
거기 통해서도 확인을 할 수 있지만
황금성이 도대체 높은 지역이
어디냐라고 궁금하시면 댓글 남겨
주시면 제가 황금성이 높은 지역을
토대로 영상을 또 한번 찍도록
하겠습니다. 예. 그리고 궁금한 거
있으시면 언제든지 이메일 보내 주시면
저희가 친절하게 어 상담도 해
드리니까 그것도 참고하시면 좋을 것
같습니다. 그리고 제가 책에 나와서
여러분 계속 홍보를 해야 됩니다.
그래서 책에 이런 사례들뿐만 아니라
어 자세한 내용까지 좀 담겨져
[음악] 있기 때문에 교보문고에서
빌사나 검색해시면 아마 상단에 있을
거예요. 그래서 그 책 참고하셔
가지고 좀 빌딩 투자하는데 도움
되셨으면 좋겠습니다. 오늘 영상
여기까지 하겠습니다. 감사합니다.